hey everybody its charlie we got a dew
patrol trailer to break down we have to
freak out about cyborgs we finally see
what he looks like on screen with
finished special effects this is actual
footage that they shot for a promo just
to be holiday themed I don't know if
they just clip this out of one of the
episodes or if they shot it special just
for a promo because reading into
Christmas so everyone's getting their
holiday themed teasers out there's also
a bunch of Justice Society and in
Justice Society news inside the DC TV
universe all explained that after I talk
about Doom Patrol stuff don't forget
about the Titans finale I'll do a season
two teaser video because they did
something that people been asking for
for a long time myself included like it
was rumors that they were gonna do
something special and they totally did
it if you're new to the channel we're
doing a new round of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this so let's just talk about
cyborgs first because he's probably the
biggest new thing in this although crazy
Jane and Timothy Dalton's version of the
chief are new additions since the Doom
Patrol episode on Titans so I'll explain
some of the changes they've made since
you saw that episode or if you didn't
watch it what was going on with it
first reaction is is cyborg is pretty
much what I expected they said that you
know because they don't have like two
hundred million dollars to shoot these
ten to eleven or twelve episodes I don't
know exactly how many episodes do Patrol
is gonna be but since Titans was only 11
I'm guessing the Doom Patrol is
somewhere around the same you know
between 10 and 13 episodes they had to
find a way to do a really cool version
of cyborg on about half the amount of
time and say you know close to like half
the budget of what you would see cyborgs
in and Justice League or Batman vs
Superman he'll be knee was really only
in there for a couple seconds in Batman
vs Superman but the way the actor
explained it as it was pitched to him
when he first came on the series is that
it would just be a mixture of practical
and special effects you know mostly
practical stuff when he's just sitting
around and then special effects when
he's actually using his powers so if he
weren't sure what you were looking at
here this is purely practical like he's
got a piece he's wearing on top of his
head it's real like you could actually
touch it in his left eye just a little
LED light that they can turn on and off
then he's got a practical chest plate
that he wears on underneath his adidas
jacket there so the obvious solution is
that you just put him in human clothes
what he's walking around and he doesn't
need to be like super hardcore badass
cyborg like if they're not fighting some
big team of villains
the way they originally pitched the
character to us when they were like oh
you know here's a synopsis for the Doom
Patrol TV series is that cyborg is the
character that brings them their mission
that sort of sets them off on their
series like their big arc mr. nobody is
the villain he's being played by Alan
Tudyk he's from the Grant Morrison run
he doesn't appear anywhere in this but
that's just because they want it to be a
more lighter themed holiday you know hey
you know welcome everybody we're coming
February 15th so obviously that's the
premiere date if you guys didn't notice
that they're essentially billing this
team if you're not a big Doom Patrol fan
because they're a super deep cut as the
world's weirdest superheroes so that's
why all their powers are really weird
they have really crazy origin stories
crazy Jane who's like a brand-new
character that they've added since the
Doom Patrol Titans episode has probably
one of the most hardcore origin stories
once you understand how some of these
characters work you understand why you
haven't seen them on the CW DC TV shows
because those tend to be a little bit
lighter and for a slightly younger
audience so as a little girl crazy Jane
was abused by her father and developed
an alternate personality which then took
over later in life while she was living
as that alternate personality she was
abused again in a much worse way and had
to be institutionalized after it caused
her to fracture into many many different
personalities that if you remember the
dominators from the CW DC TV crossover a
couple years ago those aliens they set
off a gene bomb that she was exposed to
giving all of her different
personalities superpowers so each
different personality has a different
superpower she's kind of like a female
version of the Legion character if
you've ever seen that TV series or
you've read the comic she's not quite as
powerful as Legion is but all of her
different personalities are really weird
and I'm sure that they're probably gonna
pick some of the really crazy ones to do
but because it's only gonna be 10 to 13
episodes we're probably not gonna see
every one of the hundred different
personalities if you didn't watch the
Doom Patrol episode of Titans brenden
fraiser is playing robot man you
probably detected his voice is the
different actor underneath the costume
so brendan fraiser is just doing the
voice but also really famous person matt
bomer is playing negative man underneath
all those raps it's the same situation
different actor underneath the wraps
matt bomer just doing the voice if you
didn't know if you haven't been watching
this is a spinoff
of the Titans TV show they're building
out a connected universe so there was a
Doom Patrol episode that introduced the
beast boy character and gave his
backstory with the Doom Patrol in the
comics not all of the live-action TV
shows they've announced will be
connected though I think Swamp Thing is
supposed to be the exception because
that's taking place down in the Bayou
but we'll get more information about
that soon I'm just guessing the only
reason why they don't have Timothy
Dalton in this promo as the chief is
because he's probably is super busy
there was a different actor playing the
chief during that Titans episode I think
Timothy Dalton we could all agree is
probably a big upgrade I don't know why
they would decide to recast the after
the play the chief during the Titans
episode is a good actor but I just
wasn't a fan of what they did with the
character during that particular
performance so Timothy Dalton is a huge
upgrade I can't wait to see what he
looks like and feels like as that
character but just to be clear this is
Doom Patrol it is meant to be super
weird so even though like Titans was a
little bit darker than you may have
expected they're more mainstream
superhero teams so they're probably more
of what you're used to if you've been
watching the CW DC TV series moving into
Justice Society and in Justice Society
if you guys didn't hear there's a star
girl TV series that's coming up later
this year they're doing the Justice
Society in a really big way like they've
actually cast a bunch of the characters
and the in Justice Society yes I do
think that they would get more eyeballs
on the TV series if they just called it
just a society instead of calling a star
girl but I think for the most part
she'll be the protagonist and you'll see
the Justice Society through her
perspective this is actually pretty
funny Joel McHale like pretty big name
is gonna be playing star-spangled kid
I'm sure he'll be exactly what you would
expect of a Joel McHale performance he
tends to play snarky characters in all
the roles that he portrays so I'm not
expecting any wild deviation from that
they just cast dr. midnight Lou Ferrigno
jr. is gonna be playing our man I've
never seen him in anything before but I
do think that it's funny that Lou
Ferrigno the Hulk's son is going to be
playing at Justice Society character
they also just announced that they're
doing wild cat and I'm assuming that
this is gonna be a much bigger better
version than the arrow version of wild
cat that was a bit of a disappointment
like they brought the character on he
trained Laurel as Black Canary for like
a really brief period and then he sort
of bitched out on the Serie
enjoined another TV series so they never
brought him back like he got his ass
beat by brick and that was the end of it
you never saw him again the injustice
society characters that they've
announced so far are tigress
Sportsmaster if you're big Young Justice
fan they're finally doing Sportsmaster
on TV in another character called Dragon
King but there's only three so I'm
assuming they'll name more in just a
society characters as we go along it
will be premiering til later this year
and also you know quick premiere
reminder Young Justice season 3 speaking
of Young Justice characters like
Sportsmaster starting January 4th
they're dropping three episodes they've
given me screeners for those first three
episodes but I haven't had a chance to
watch them yet so I'll do a couple Young
Justice videos when we get closer to the
premiere they'll start dropping some
more footage for that soon too so
everybody let me know what you think
about this new live-action version of
cyborg because I don't think that we're
gonna see a cyborg movie anytime soon
even though I do think that Ray Fisher
will return as the cyborg character in
the flash movie don't forget about the
Titans finale because they dropped a
really big bomb on everybody I mean it
was a really big fan question that
people had about a certain character
they were hoping there were rumors
finally confirmed and it gives you an
idea for where the direction is headed
next season there are a couple really
big Justice League level characters that
they introduced during Titan season 1
and this is just a continuation of that
so no spoilers in this video but I'll
talk about that when I post my Titans
video later while you wait for
everything click here to rewatch all
those Titans Batman scenes and click
here for that new Thor 4 reunion men and
black international trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
see you guys tonight